هناك ايضا تقصير من معظم الدول
الاسلاميه في المنطقه العربيه
وغيرها بالرغم ايضا من المسؤوليه
الايمانيه والدينيه والاخلاقيه
والانسانيه من جهه وبالرغم من مصلحه الامه
كل كل الامه في ان تقف مع الشعب
الفلسطيني في مواجهه عدو مشترك هو دو
للمسلمين جميعا يعاديهم ويستهدف ويتامل
عليهم في دينهم وفي دنياهم ويستهدف بكل
اشكال
الاستهداف وبالرغم من الخطوره الكبيره على
امتنا في
التخاذل تجاه ما يفعله العدو الصهيوني
اليهودي الاسرائيلي ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني
المسلم
العزيز فعندما تعتمد الدول الاسلاميه في
البلدان العربيه
وغيرها استراتيجيه التخاذل والتفرج تجاه
الشعب
الفلسطيني سيكون هذا هو الحال مع اي بلد
مسلم اخر سواء من البلدان العربيه او
غيرها سيتفرغ